who is the best spider-man of them all
toby vs. andrew versus tom the stickiest
threesome ever hey everyone Marc Ellis
here on the show where we drop the puck
on a scintillating matchup in the world
of movies TV and hopefully not books
here's how it works three rounds round
one box office round two tomato meter
round three power and responsibility
plus a wild card round number one is box
office spider-man has been a fixture at
the top of the box office he first
debuted on the big screen in 2002 that
year Tobey Maguire upside down kissed
his way into our hearts to the tune of
three total films that grossed a
combined three point three billion
dollars worldwide the first two were
great and the third one probably made me
miss Nickelback after getting cheated
out of his Facebook shares pool Peter
Andrew Garfield stepped into the reboot
the amazing spider-man and its lone
sequel the two combined collected 1.6
billion dollars here on planet earth
then Sony sent a lot of emails that we
all read and somehow Marvel was able to
secure the again rebooted Tom Holland
spider boy into MCU if you combine the
three movies - Tom Holland has already
appeared in as spider-man they've done
4.1 billion dollars worth of business
that's almost enough money to buy Star
Wars almost here's my take Toby's got
three standalone movies that did over a
billion bucks apiece and that's even
more impressive considering he didn't
have like 38 other Avengers or talking
raccoon in the film's to help him that
was all on his shoulders selling those
tickets neither of Andrew Garfield's
flicks cracked the billion mark oh boy
and Tom Holland homecoming didn't quite
hit a billion dollars either I'm sad I'm
intimidated mr. stark I'm not feeling so
good the edge is going to Toby take on
this
[Music]
round two tomato meter tobey maguire his
highest-rated spider-man movie is
spider-man 2 at 93% his lowest rated
spider-man 3 predictably at 63% still
fresh so his average of his three movies
82 that'll get you in to most state
colleges up next is Andrew Garfield his
first attempt that spider-man is 72% on
the tomato meter however the amazing
spider-man 2 52% and it has the
distinction of being the only spider-man
film that is rotten his average 62
percent so moving on to Tom Holland his
high is his movie spider-man homecoming
92% his low is Avengers infinity war 84%
but he survives to snap 89 percent for
his average that's three fresh movies so
far Tom Holland you're a young kid but
you're getting a big win you take round
number two round number three power last
responsibility it's great power comes
yeah we all know the phrase but who
amongst these arachnid folk had the most
power or the most responsibility
it ain't Tom Holland look he's got
chores around the house but he's got
tons of shoulder pads core reactors
magical hammers to lean on when the
fightin gets serious I give Tom a lot of
credit for taking on the vulture and he
got in some good licks against Thanos
but his first fight in the MCU it was
against Captain America that's not a
fight that's a scrimmage look I love
what you did against ant-man keep
watching the old movies you're not
winning this round it's between Andrew
and Tobey they both had to juggle
homework with a solid love interest but
Andrew Garfield he had to deal with his
love interest not making out of the
second film plus he tangled with the
lizard in his first movie and then the
trifecta of electro green goblin and
Russian Paul Giamatti in the amazing
spider-man 2 that's a whole lot of
responsibility some may even say too
much for one movie like don't cram all
that responsibility into a third act
speaking of shoehorns toby fought off
both venom and sandman in spider-man 3
and he also lost the battle to his need
to dance but come on let's talk about
the most epic clash he ever had
that was the memorable one against doc
ock in spider-man 2 and I'll throw in
the original tangle with Green Goblin in
there as well
so both Toby and Andrew handled their
responsibilities incredibly well but
Garfield also had the added pressure of
dealing with Gwen Stacy's dad who's a
cop played by Denis Leary yeah I mean
you are in for a lifetime of rough
Thanksgiving table conversation I saw a
video on the Internet
oh you saw the video on the Internet
well then the case is closed
good luck with that Andy you win the
round Wow
oh it's getting good in here we got
three spider-man duking it out each one
has a round of their credit so far so we
moved to the wild card we thought about
going with a suit but that felt like
cheating because Tom Holland has the
Tony Stark cheddar in his let's consider
the overall Webb's Manship of these
three fellows one can't talk about
Webb's Manship a word that I just
invented you can put that in Webster's
dictionary in time per move you know
Andrew Garfield he averages using his
web four minutes per movie Tobey Maguire
trail seems slightly 3.8 minutes per
movie Tom Holland a distant third he
only uses that web two minutes per flick
here young kid you'll you'll learn how
to last longer and now the toughest part
of my job besides driving here Southern
California traffic I got to pick a
winner I'm going Tobey Maguire that's
right you still got a teat he's the
original he helped usher in the Golden
Age of comic book movies and his webs
playing right from the wrist his are
organic while the other two they had to
build a device to shoot the web and it
call me old-fashioned I like organic
natural free-range webbing and that's
what Tobey Maguire brings to the table
as Peter Parker's slash inspire me but
it doesn't matter who I think is the
best I'm just one man of below-average
intelligence it's your turn
you're the viewer you have all the power
and with great power comes comes great
responsibility
responsible you figured it out comment
and let us know your favorite spider-man
of them all tell us why that spider-man
is your favorite Goong whippersnapper
named Peter Parker make sure y'all check
out Miles Morales a spider-man in
spider-man into the spite of Earth
because it's a great movie thanks for
tuning in this week we'll see you real
soon